grandma never got up early dad could
even get up early I guess I'm not the
kind of person who can rise before the
Sun and what I would suggest to you is
simply this the first 60 minutes or so
are very clearly defined and that's the
recipe I use to set up the rest of the
day first of all your morning routine
starts the night before so go to bed
early want to be happy
build a life not just a business hey
Tibbie Carmichael and this channel was
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you as well you've
got Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believed life and learn the morning
routines of super successful people
enjoy okay let's kick it off with
routine number one rise up super early
with Robin Sharma there's a reason why
the visionary founder of Starbucks
Howard Schultz Rises before the Sun
there's a reason why Michelle Obama rice
very early there's a reason why Tim Cook
leaving Apple gets up before the dawn
first of all the hours between 4 & 6 are
the time of least distraction in this
age of dramatic interruption
number two the hours before the Sun
rises is the period where your brain is
most available to your primary
creativity so while you're sleeping your
brain actually washes itself but also it
lets them go the residue of the previous
day while you are resting and while you
are recovering when you wake up your
thinking is fresh your creativity is
most pristine you are most available to
access your gifts and your talents so
those are some of the reasons why I
encourage you to get a Braille you might
say Robin while I'm not an early riser I
can't put mine over mattress I can't win
the battle up the bed grandma I never
got up early
dad couldn't get up early I guess about
the kind of person who could rise before
the Sun and what I would suggest to you
is simply this means what science
confirms in particular the data of
University College London you do any new
habit practice it for 66 days and you
will arrive at the place of automaticity
in other words it'll be easier to run
the new habit than not 266 days of
rising at 5:00 a.m. will get you to a
place where it's easier to get up at 5
a.m. then not to get up at 5 a.m. you'll
reach a place of automaticity
in my book the five am club I say all
change is hard at first and it's messy
in the middle and it's gorgeous
at the end routine number two put
yourself first with Mel Robbins why is
the morning routine so important couple
things
how you wake up has a scientifically
proven impact on your ability to focus
on your happiness and on your
productivity all day the two to three
pieces of it are for me I wake up when
the alarm goes off I then get up and for
the first couple minutes of the day I
plan my day and I have a particular
process that I go through that leverages
something from Harvard Business School
called the progress principle I have a
mindfulness practice that could be
anything that you want it could be
gratitude journaling it could be
meditation it could be five slow deep
breaths it could be taking your your dog
outside for a walk and then on mornings
when I can I have a micro exercise
practice where I do planks for five
minutes or I do something to get my
blood pumping on the mornings that I can
I and I do all that before I ever even
look at my phone because I put myself
and my mindset first deliberately before
I ever allow the world access to my mind
you do not want anybody to have access
to what's going on up here until you've
gotten deliberate about what you're
thinking about first routine number
three Journal with Tim Ferriss the first
60 minutes or so are very clearly
defined and that's the recipe I use to
set up the rest of the day step number
one I wake up and I meditate for 20
minutes typically 22 minutes it's 20
minutes of seated Transcendental
Meditation it could be pasta it could be
headspace and then 2 minute
decompression period where I sit there
and let my mind do whatever it wants to
do I get up brew tea very frequently
hulong tea or some combination of say
turmeric ginger and ku air that's
another favorite and then I sit down to
journal and there are two different
types of journaling that I do depending
on the day
for different purposes one would be
morning pages where I'm effectively
vomiting my brain onto the page to trap
my monkey mind in print so that it
doesn't bother me for the rest of the
day the other type of journaling I do is
best encapsulated in a journal called
the five minute journal they're
different ways to do this but I'm
writing down three or four bullets of
items people relationships anything that
I'm grateful for which is a very very
very nice way to set the rest of the day
so that you're viewing life through a
lens of positivity then there are a few
questions related or prompts I should
say related to focal points for the day
ideally immediately after that I'm
having a small amount to eat and then I
would go into exercise of some type that
exercise could be riding on a on a
peloton bike and doing a 20-minute hit
workout high-intensity interval training
or it could be a crow yoga or could be
weight training or working on a concept
to rower and that would be generally no
more than 60 to 90 minutes in length
sometimes it's as short as 20 minutes
and then shower off to the day also if
you want to have more confidence and
self-love check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join on the
description button everybody gives too
much rubbish about what everybody else
thinks
and you know who they think the mother
worry the most but a lot of the anxiety
that we feel is actually due to using
words that are not defined very well
once you can meet yourself with
compassion then you can begin to let go
of whatever it is that's really with
your mindset you can get back on track
you can refocus and don't wait til
Monday and that's a mistake that
everybody makes routine number four go
to bed earlier with Tom bill you first
of all your morning routine starts the
night before so go to bed early but I
tried to go to bed as close to 9:00 as
humanly possible every night save for
the weekends and in that I sleep without
an alarm so I wake up when I wake up the
reason that I do that is because I want
to get as much sleep as I need so I'm
all about cognitive optimization so I'm
not somebody who sets the alarm to make
sure that I'm up at 4:00 in the morning
but when I wake up at 4:00 in the
morning I'm a very happy camper I
usually get it used to be between 5:00
and 6:00 I'm now getting between 7 & 8 I
have no idea why it changed completely
randomly and as far as I can tell
without reason but I wake up when I wake
up I give myself 10 minutes to get out
of bed and I do that because I'm lazy
and my inclination is to lay in bed so I
need a bright line that says I get out
of bed immediately without wasting time
so I'm out of bad and out of bed in 10
minutes or less I put my gym clothes
next to my bed so that the easiest
answer is to put my gym clothes on in
fact I'd have to make a conscious choice
not to which the sleep would trigger in
me a lot of conflict emotionally because
it is my identity to immediately go to
the gym to workout again partly for
cognitive optimization and then also for
longevity for health and for aesthetics
but working out I think is incredibly
important and I actually think that for
anybody that wants to achieve something
extraordinary in their life that the
third thing that you need to focus on is
mindset the first two are diet and
exercise followed by mindset so I hit
the gym first and foremost immediately
after the gym I meditate and the reason
that I do that is because I want to
practice going from the sympathetic
nervous system which is fight-or-flight
which are triggering in the gym through
the heavy exertion your
heart rate is up your breathing is
shallow and rapid and the idea is to
very quickly switch over into the
parasympathetic nervous system where
you're getting into rest and digest
where you're calming all of that down
you're slowing your breath your
diaphragm breathing in through the nose
out through the mouth and really calming
everything down and I think practicing
that transition is very important and so
that's why I do them back-to-back but
then on top of that just meditating for
any reason I think is really important
routine number five get in control of
your brain with John Assaraf
when I wake up in the morning the first
thing I do is I do a gratitude exercise
where I ask myself use the in bed what
am I most grateful for today
and usually you know I'm grateful for my
health I'm grateful for my wife I'm
grateful for my children grateful to be
alive I'm grateful you know for my
family I'm grateful to to have
experiences and use do you do that
eyes closed yeah I do that eyes closed
and while I while I think about that I
feel it and so the feeling starts every
day with a great feeling
mmm I start every day with a great
feeling you know do you visualize some
things you've liked your children or do
you talk to yourself how do you do that
yeah I have an internal dialogue I see
images of the things that I'm thinking
about and that just takes me two minutes
just two minutes when I wake up and then
I go to exercise to take care of my body
how long usually one hour to an hour and
15 minutes every day and so I do a
variety of different things I hike I
bike I work on aerobics that work on
strength I work with weights I do
whatever it is I just do it to give my
body the physical exercise then as soon
as I finish my exercise in my chair one
hour and an hour now or 15 minutes at
the most so then in my gym I have two
things I have a vision board which is my
dream board for my class I know you all
know about that
yes so I have my vision board for my my
physique in my body in my health but
then I also have in in my gym something
called Anna
bored okay so I would say I achieved
some of the things that I achieved based
on the future
no achieved in the past yes so fast
you're fast in the future yeah so I have
in my in my gym in my home gym I have a
like a place where I sit and before I
start my meditation I look at my vision
board from the past okay
so I get connected to the different
things that I've been able to achieve
and I remember every day when I set my
mind and my focus to achieving goals I
can achieve all of my goals but what I
also do is I reinforce most people focus
on what's not working just isn't going
well this didn't work I want to remind
myself every day yeah look how many
things I was able to accomplish by being
clear by being passionate by using these
rituals so before I go into my
meditation which isn't with my eyes
closed I look at my acheived board I get
emotionally associated with it to remind
myself that when I set my mind to
achieve something I can do it and then I
look across because I have a mirror in
the gym and I look across and I say I
love you just the way you are and I said
I accept you just the way you are with
all of your skills and passion and
faults and insecurities and doubts and
fears I accept you just the way you are
why and I smile and then I close my eyes
and I do about a 15 minute meditation
well and in my meditation sometimes I
have no thoughts where I'm just one with
the universe and every intern other
times I'll just follow my thoughts then
I'll just pay attention be mindful of
were they going this morning where they
going today so I'll follow my thoughts
and I'll just follow them other times
I'll follow a thought and say release
that one and follow another thoughts a
release that one so I am teaching
I brain that I am in control of my brain
and routine number six the last one
before of every special bonus routine is
don't hit the snooze button with jockle
Bullock
don't press snooze snooze doesn't help
but snooze is one of those things that
just series is a dream killer yeah it's
like it's popular the dreams that score
that's the truth yeah it's like a
complete think it's gonna help you dream
more but it's not destroy your dreams
it's a psychological trick if you must
lose the thing that you think pressing
the snooze helps you with like a little
just get that extra eight minutes to
sleep that eight minutes to sleep
ability to be anywhere energy by the way
18 seconds there's there's an 18 second
window in the morning when your alarm
goes off that sucks
it's about 18 seconds so 18 that the
alarm goes off that you touch it then
the next 18 seconds are like hard there
that's when you have to use maximum
effort to clear the gravitational pull
of your pillow
if you can get away from those 18
seconds then you're okay you just get up
get away from the pillow and it's
pulling you in some tractor beam I'm
gonna get away from that and so that 18
seconds and once you're up there moving
you're good now a special bonus clip
from David Goggins on how to structure
your day that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing question let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go question number one
what time will you go to bed and wake up
tomorrow morning number two how can you
put yourself first and number three
where do you need to get in control of
your brain and if you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you give
me a hash tag believe down the comments
as well so walk me through a day in the
life what's it look like right now well
I mean it's got to be crazy right now I
leave here and I fly out to Oregon and
I'll be an organ with Cameron Hayes
we'll be getting after for a few days a
lot more podcast lot more interviews but
every day every morning I get up I still
get my run in every morning how do you
structure the training the training is
basically structured off of my schedule
so look at my schedule yeah that's okay
Jennifer would we have today we have
this at 7 o'clock in the morning Roger
that that means I gotta be up by 4
o'clock in the morning to run that's how
it works that's all my works so she lays
out the schedule of events to out you
just you just set it two hours earlier
she says it could take an hour to get
two rich rolls let's say we were at 7
o'clock today in the morning it takes an
hour to get two rich rolls with no
traffic ok that's that's blocking an
hour 15 for rich roll okay we got that
good morning tom I'm gonna run 7 miles
this morning I need 52:34 that Roger
that put in a shower shave add that in
so the schedule dictates but I have all
my [ __ ] back right so that means getting
up at 1:30 trust me
Roger that I've done that several times
yeah several how much sleep do you
usually get I like getting 7 to 8 hours
of sleep nowadays I can do that but
there's times where the schedule says
hey man you're getting three hours and
if that's the case
right Merry Christmas
[Music]
if you want to learn three simple steps
to build discipline in 2020 check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
you want to get a jump on life get the
hell out of bed in the morning I call
that snooze alarm the dream killer like
when you put on you when you press that
snooze button you're killing your dreams